in this video we're going to talk a
bunch about this fantastic number e to
the j omega t
and one of the coolest things that's
going to happen here we're going to
bring together what we know about
complex numbers and this exponential
form of of complex numbers and sines and
cosines as a function of time and what
we're going to end up with is the idea
of a number that spins
i think this is really one of the
coolest things in in electronics and
it's really that the essence of all
signal processing theory
so this number here e to the j omega t
this is based on euler's formula
just as a reminder euler's formula is
e to the j we'll use theta as our
variable
equals
cosine theta
plus
j
times sine of theta
that's one form of euler's formula
and the other form is with a negative up
in the exponent we say e to the minus j
theta
equals cosine
minus
j sine theta
now if i go and plot this what it looks
like is this
so if i plot this on a complex plane and
that's a plane that has
a real axis
and an imaginary axis
now we remember that j is the
is the variable that we use for the
imaginary unit
j squared is equal to -1 and we use that
in electrical engineering instead of i
one way to express this number is by
plotting it on this complex plane and so
if i pick out a location for
for some complex number
and i say oh okay this is
the x coordinate is cosine of theta
and what's this coordinate here
on the j axis on the j axis
that's sine theta
and if i draw a line right through
our number this is the angle theta
so this is one of the representations of
complex numbers is this euler's formula
or the exponential form
and we can represent it this way here
this notation is challenging i i can't
help but every time i look at this i
start to do e to the complex to
something and
everything i know about exponential
taking exponents and things like that it
kind of confuses me in my head
but what i've done over time is
basically say
e to the j anything
that whole thing is a complex number and
this is what this complex number looks
like right there
so let's take a look at some of the
properties of this complex number all
right one of the things we can ask is
what is the magnitude of e
to the j
theta
if i put magnitude absolute value or
magnitude bars around that
and what that says is what is this value
here for r
and we can figure that out using
the pythagorean theorem
right what we know is
this squared
equals
x value squared which is cosine
plus the y value squared which is sine
theta
so it equals cosine
squared of theta
plus
sine squared
of theta
okay that's just we just applied the
pythagorean theorem to this this right
triangle right here this this right
triangle
now from trigonometry from trigonometry
we know what what's the value of this
cosine squared plus sine squared for any
angle equals
1.
so that tells us that e to the j theta
magnitude squared is equal to 1 or that
e to the j theta magnitude is also one
and so we we write down
e to the j
theta
the magnitude of that is equal to one
let's go back to our friend up here that
says that the length of this vector this
is a complex number that is distance one
away from the origin
so we'll tuck that away we know that the
magnitude of e to the j theta is one and
i can actually go over here
and draw
now a circle on here like this
and if i put the circle right through
there
there's the unit circle and it has a
radius of one
so i know that for any value of theta
that my
my complex number e to the j theta
it's going to be somewhere on this
yellow circle
so e to the j theta is somewhere on this
circle and the angle is what the angle
is right here it's whatever is
multiplied by j up in that exponent
anything that multiplies by j that's an
angle
so what if i wanted something that was
not on the unit circle what if i wanted
something that was farther away from the
origin than that well what i would do is
i would say
i would take a
some some amplitude
e to the j theta
and this amplitude would expand the
length of that vector so
i would say if i wanted to know how far
away it is
well the magnitude of e to the j theta
is 1 and the magnitude of a is a so this
equals a
and if i was to sketch in a circle for
that let's say a was a little bit bigger
than one
it would be a little bit bigger out and
this would have a value here
that would be a value of a the radius
would be a
pretty flexible notation
so with this notation we can represent
any number in the complex plane with
with this kind of format here
we'll take a little break here and in
the next video we'll put in for theta
we'll put in an argument that has to do
with time and we'll see what happens to
this complex exponential